hey chip shot we're here Marrakech
rajbhandari primo GTA 5 modification
experts all in your GTA garages pullin
tweaking things I said garages that's
right is that the samurais guerrido I
mean that's the righteous pronunciation
the ocean understand coming out of money
I didn't get that you were making like
an autobody show a modification ll here
they're like changing the screws mr.
market GTA 5 enhancements nice you guys
go up on the funniest videos of CR
gamespot com in a long time GTA 5 mods
I'm gonna make this a weekly show I
guess we'll find out we'll see if they
keep making fun mods they we might have
to you guys have given doping in my math
is just made of melted butter today you
guys have dovin deep into the world of
GTA mods ya have for the past week or so
how is it does it work well is it fought
are there good mods etter at their like
top level down what do you think there's
something once definitely does not work
well um what you did not see in the
video is that our computer crashed four
times all right when they once you see a
crash it was three hours of us playing
around and restarting a computer edited
down to 15 minutes so it is a long time
to find the mods to figure out if they
work then to get the camera to the strip
club the cow into the strip oh yes you
get stage side menus fellas look how
worth it that is that's everything it's
so it's so freaking fun it is so awesome
and I love it but it's problematic it
needs work I mean so so the mods took a
while to that they crashed every once a
while how long it take to install them
how long what was that process not a
problem at all so yeah there's there's a
guy named Alexander blade who made the
native trainer enact kind of the
groundwork for all these of mods which
kind of just you know following to the
form that i plug into that yeah and
you'd it's literally a drag drop so i
don't ya as you know like um which was
funny enough is like the day
that we were coming to this the day we
were going to record and rocks are put
out a patch yeah and basically band that
site or the native trainer that did it
break it intentionally or addy yes they
heard this okay and they also add a
warning out saying that they were going
to start banning people they were being
serious about it when we started the
game it was busted so it was a quick fix
though Rob found a patch put that in and
oh yeah I mean it and it fixed it Jesus
outlook fixed yeah definitely feasible
oh my god lopevi gets look good funny
I'm talking again they're funny and well
I were we'll get into like interesting
stuff is you know the main dilemma is
like um they're banning people
specifically online yes for their mods
and that's fair that's totally
reasonable right like get people running
around hack in the game yeah a set of
ruin other people's experience I most
microtransactions you're saying oh yeah
like there's money involved ya soon
Clara's different things so like I was
even just um I'm making a video right
now right using the director mode where
mom's coming effect works like it's
better in that in director mode what i
can do is i can I can't be a dolphin
what does it take to get to the dolphin
well I've got to go find the peyote
plant rice water and get it so that's
that's a step right there really an hour
or a long time right and so now here's
this you know there's this the one we
use in our video right it's called um
bodyguard spot where I can spawn other
people other things anything in the game
the director mode in GTA does not have
that yeah it does not have a spot which
which basically creates you're seeing
cuz if you congratulate I mean how much
of a video you can do with just you as a
character you know I mean you would like
to have an interaction you'd want to
create some kind of some some crime
scene right so these bars are coming out
and they're allowing that and that is
something that you like you can't you
can't just like deny right like people
are doing it well the director mode
seems very much to be like a oh that you
did something cool in the game here you
can now sort of make a 20 second clip of
it and make it look like more than just
gameplay
is easy to be like okay here or is the
breast of the tools for the game right
what I'm for exactly like every animal
like even for instance you know you go
again you go together gonna go to put a
peyote plant to get the mound line the
mountain lion is only gonna be one color
it's gonna be whatever however you
unlocked it so it's gonna be you know
Brown here's all mods I can you can get
every shade and every different type of
about different shades of Wales and if
the green that lies are reason enough to
justify mods I don't know what it or you
can just fire humpback whales out of
here I love here you still spawning them
as you're crashing god mode so we can we
did find out there is a limit to how
many whales and before crashes your he
thought it was so many there's my shots
I did get to throw in we just kind of
surveyed what we did yeah especially a
crash but it was I can't I mean what
five dozen iron is so much more
potential for unlimited creativity you
can do anything you can think of and you
break the game in so many ways you're
not even supposed to be able to beat in
this hangar yeah this is not a area
you're supposed to be able to be it's a
plane you spot and yeah yeah you guys
went back to Northampton as well at one
stage in the room it's right i mean the
ability to go to these places and have
ricky's bed you know man these things
are so fast to be able to do i mean in
the spectrum of it cherie i took us
three hours scandalous footage but we
did a lot in three hours that if you
needed to go get that peyote or you
needed to go to the particular areas
this would take forever it's just like
lets you do everything off as soon as
you want it now now now I think that's
what's important is you guys have been
talking about it from a director
perspective and cuz your goal in some
ways is to make video that's your job
but from a purse from a player's
perspective just wanting to get her in
get in and mess around it seems like
it's really easy to try to make your own
little weird Noah's Ark cargo plane
right like you can just fire it up and
start doing that stuff that was just an
idea Rob like had he was inspired to
make Noah's plane and there's nothing I
love it it took forever but we did it
this is the site so I great ending this
like throw everything
here's cats so the trainers are like
this is almost like step one of every
game when it comes out every mod is like
okay you've got all the assets make them
spawn whenever you want yeah why do you
guys seen like what's the next evolution
of GTA 5 mods what's coming out next so
what's really funny is I was just on the
subreddit for GTA mods and some 14 hours
ago had already basically said hey guys
since they're banning people online and
supposedly there are rumors of like even
if you're hooked up to internet you're
only a single player you can still get
banned oh really it's okay how long is
the bad it's like 15 days seems like a
minimum I don't know depends I'm sure in
the case but um this guy had already
made here's it I don't know I haven't
even tried out but here's a basically an
interface where you can turn him off
turn off the ones online do this like
right basically a launcher is what it is
um that's four hours ago right like and
then I saw another video for you know uh
people are just making these insane mods
already I'm a trained you can drive with
all the trains instead of flying flying
cars train simulator in GTA 5 there are
simple ones twos well I got goats
another yeah oh god there's ones that
like we didn't put in the video because
they weren't like in crate incredibly
amazing but they were still awesome like
being able to see your speed being able
to do it down all the windows even the
back windows so you could see better it
was really cool and the little ones I
think are what makes this place so
special because if you just want to be
able to have Michael have a purse
there's a good for that the randomized
clothes option was one of the funniest
things I've seen another surface area
here's the gravity gun right this was
one day no I saying it's great I think
that these mods are fantastic in there
like humorous potential creative
potential is undeniable I just feel like
there will never be a time when rock
star is like cool but this seems crazy
for it because like GTA one had a
massive modding community gt2 at a huge
one g j3 on pc was like insane like this
is nothing new for the world lacrosse
what did people poking around in there
got that then hot coffee happened like
yes that I mean the amount of things
you guys are talking about like
wholesome animal fun and like silly
purse carrying things like just think
about the shears breath of things that
are in GTA like what kind of weird and
horrible stuff could come out of this
and then become the narrative of GTA
four right and then you compare 425
where it's like 40 had like an online
part which was you know popular but now
you have this GTA online which is just a
perfect segue from single player to
lighten online I feel like just how they
have set this up it's just like a Ricky
I'm try say is like you don't want
people to be easily going back and forth
right you want a torpedo your online
yeah by allowing mods that could have
any access yes you should talk to you've
already seen yeah weird stuff going in
and online no somebody has tinkered
because there's flying people in a
sudden and that's not supposed to happen
so I understand a can't condone it but I
mean yeah maybe being a bit more
connected to it at one last thing the
big thing that always happens with GJ
one and two with three and it didn't
really happen before do you think GTA 5
modding will have whole new levels are
there people working on like are you
seeing it in the subreddit at all where
people are like working on making new
cities there's still some ways ago um I
would say what you can expect next or
like kind of like opening up locations
that you have done in the game right
like maybe just wrap the bat you load up
the game the first level is when you rot
in the bank with you know in northern
ain't it that's their right that's
somewhere some can open that up and you
got like all the heist missions like the
aircraft carrier yes is not around oh
but it's in there so so those you'll
you'll see those first right and even
interiors I mean you talked about the
interior of the cargo plane is not
something you're supposed to be all
access what about all these buildings
that you know like all Sun you can go
into the clucking bell or whatever yeah
I mean oh man I just want them to make
san andreas do you want to don't race he
wants your San Francisco and there
somebody somewhere is got to be doing it
you'd hope so and we'll hear about in
four years yeah well this is maybe could
maybe sooner cuz we were with the the
amount of stuff to mary robinson in
only a week of this being up has already
been fantastic so that videos up on
gamespot com is there going to be
another you working on something at the
moment I'm working on a documentary on
the mountain lion okay do you relieve it
there ya go alright check that out on
gamespot com real soon head and we are
always checking there is like a website
where you can see the latest mods that
are out we basically check it every once
in a while and when there's something we
just know is gonna be good we'll
probably just make another one and you
could do another be right yeah yeah it's
just about like picking let's do it
we're silent look yeah let's do it